for nearly nine decades cloris leachman
was a force in hollywood
who can forget her as the oldest
competitor ever on dancing with the
stars
cloris energy and talent were larger
than life yeah it really does make me
smile just thinking about her and all
the amazing moments that we have that
you cannot see
anywhere else if you're not there i will
rip her face off
just remember one time saying to mary
i'm mary
we're sorry you know we've got to
remember you're the star because
there was none of that kind of thing on
the set three months i've been
apologizing to you without you even
being here
i'm having an amazing life and it isn't
over yet
it wasn't oh i want to be a star in all
hollywood
ever an oscar winner for the last
picture show this comedian
was beloved for her role on the mary
tyler moore show playing mary's landlady
this cast stayed friends for decades
after the show began
the minute we see each other we're so
thrilled each one is oh yes and it
brings back all those 20 years
we got all the chummy and we dug each
other a lot
ed asner who played mary's boss lou
grant had a close bond with cloris on
and off screen
we spoke to him exclusively today what
was the impression you got of her the
first time you met her
hold on to your hands folks i want to
give you a little smile
come on there was some flirtation
between your characters
but clores told us that um you were
really fond of her which which leads to
an interesting behind the scenes
bet we decided we agreed that we'd have
uh
we do it if he lost 30 pounds
and he did well he lost 29 pounds
and we looked at each other he had one
pound to go i mean what are we going to
do
the next thing i knew he'd gained it all
back again
that made you giggle
[Music]
had more emmy nominations than any other
actress she won
eight primetime awards tying her with
julia louis dreyfus for the most ever
you are really the queen of the emmy i
like that
you like it i'll go for that i wish
that we were there i think i bring
the fun and the laughter in the and keep
things going
cloris had so many memorable roles
including the classic mel brooks
comedies
high anxiety and young frankenstein i am
paul blucher
mel paid tribute saying she could make
you laugh or cry
at the drop of a hat i adore comedy
i like to do it over and over again
until i just get sick of it everyone
loved her free spirit
at the age of 70 cloris posed naked her
body painted with fruit and vegetables
for the cover of a health magazine why
all be all covered up and everything why
not
be who you are at whatever age it
doesn't matter
and at 82 cloris and her partner corki
ballas
were fan favorites on dancing with the
stars but i've lost weight and i can't
tell you what a difference
that is to be dancing without that
stomach that i have
the mother of five once told e.t she was
thankful for every single minute
of her life every once in a while and
frequently they'll be
i have an experience of some kind i
think oh i could die now i have lived
i've had a great deal great very
privileged
she was something else now here's
something most people don't know about
cloris
before she turned to acting cloris
dreamed of being a concert pianist a
skill she once showed us
[Music]
she was a massive talent and will be
[Music]
missed